en angleterre la fugue d'une gamine de
12 ans en compagnie d'un ancien soldat
américain de 31 ans est terminée l'homme
a été arrêté en allemagne il apparaît
qu'il était bien au courant de l'âge de
la jeune fille contrairement à ce qui
avait été dit à un moment cette affaire
qui s'est heureusement bien terminée
pose tout de même à nouveau le problème
des sites de discussion sur internet ils
peuvent être facilement détourné ça on
sait par ailleurs donc comment empêcher
les enfants d'accéder à certains sites
explication rommel benon matthew beard
aide après quatre jours de fugue
la petite chèvre huntington âgée de 12
ans a retrouvée saine et sauve ses
parents dans la banlieue de manchester
la fin heureuse d'une aventure qui
pourtant aurait pu mal tourner tout
commence il y a un an sur internet
à l'époque l'adolescente se connectent à
des sites de discussion grâce à
l'ordinateur familial
les rencontres virtuelles notamment avec
cet américain de 31 ans thomistes de
baker ancien marine qui prétend avoir 19
ans après des centaines d'heures de
conversation sur le net la jeune fille
décide de retrouver à l'étranger son
amant virtuel un homme qui selon le fbi
à istres et quand souvent des sites de
pornographie enfantine
pendant tout ce temps les paroles chez
von n'auront jamais été alertés si on le
laissait des parents de cette jeune
fille lui avait dit que même si on a
sympathisé avec quelqu'un sur internet
quand on va la rencontrer physiquement
on y va accompagner on n'y va pas seul
s'il y avait eu cette démarche
d'apprentissage de l'outil qui avait été
fait pour cette jeune fille peut-être
que les l'inquiétude des parents la
jeune fille est saine et sauve
heureusement mais ça aurait pu être
dramatique et les parents n'auraient pas
n'aurait pas eu à s'inquiéter on aurait
pu éviter cette fut pour limiter les
risques des solutions techniques
existent les logiciels de contrôle
parental gratuits ou à prix modiques
peuvent être téléchargés ils permettent
d'interdire l'accès à des sites
sensibles
un filtrage qui s'appuie notamment sur
une liste noire internationale enrichit
en permanence mais la sécurité à 100%
est impossible sur internet les sites
pornographiques ou pédophile
apparaissent et disparaissent tous les
jours problème c'est qu'on identifie
souvent des machines des numéros de
machines et derrière ses machines
d'ailleurs ces numéros de machines il
n'est jamais très sûr de retrouver
l'individu en question
en angleterre une nouvelle législation
doit entrer en vigueur à l'automne
elle vise notamment les pédophiles sur
internet
en prévoyant un nouveau délit
d'attirance à des fins d'abus sexuels